if you're looking for ways to be
Fearless stand for something and believe
in your dream then this video is for you
don't allow anybody to make you
feel that you are nobody so I'm happy
tonight I'm not worried about anything
I'm not fearing any man and he went up
to the desk and he saying we don't take
negroes need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation what's up it's Evan
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe in that amazing gift you
have inside you that I want to see come
out so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew on today's lessons from
a man who went from being whipped as a
boy up to the age of 15 and being
depressed for most of his life to being
the most visible spokesperson and leader
of the Civil Rights Movement using
nonviolent tactics he's Martin Luther
King and here's my take on his top 10
rules to
success all right let's kick it off with
rule number one believe in yourself I'm
going to like this one number one in
your life's blueprint should
be a
deep Bel
belief in your own dignity your own
worth and your own
somebody don't allow anybody to make you
feel that you are
nobody always feel that you
count always feel that you have
worth and always feel that your life
has ultimate significance Martin Luther
King talking about believe I love it
I've never seen this clip before and I'm
so glad we were able to lead with it
let's move on to rule number two be
Fearless well I don't know what will
happen
now we've got some difficult days
ahead but it really doesn't matter with
me now because I've been to the
Mountaintop I don't mind
like anybody I would like to
live a long life
longevity has its
place but I'm not concerned about that
now I just want to do God's
Will and he's allowed me to go up to the
mountain and I've looked
over and I've
seen the pro promis
land I may not get there with you but I
want you to know
tonight that we as a people will get to
the promised
land go ahead go ahead so I'm happy
tonight I'm not worried about anything
I'm not fearing any man my eyes have
seen the glory of the coming of the
Lord I love this clip and I don't know
if you guys know but that was the last
speech that he ever gave because the
next day he was assassinated and so
pretty solid speech to go out on and his
message definitely rang true well beyond
his years okay coming up next rule
number three fight for yourself I come
here tonight and plead with you all
right believe in yourself and believe
that you're
somebody and as I said to group last
night nobody else can do this for us no
document can do this for
us no lonian
Emancipation Proclamation can do this
for us no konian or johnsonian Civil
Rights bill can do this for us if the
Negro is to be free he must move down
into the inner resources of his own soul
and sign with a pin an ink of self
assertive manhood his own Emancipation
Proclamation man I love that one super
powerful and just reinforces the idea
that you need to decide for yourself
before blaming anybody else for your
situation in your environment it starts
with you when you change yourself that's
when goodness starts to happen I love it
Martin Luther King that's why he's the
man let's keep going rule number four
keep moving Life For Me ain't been no
Crystal St it's had tax in it boards
torn up places with no carpet on the
floor
bear but all the
time I been climbing on and reaching
Landings and turning corners and
sometimes going in the dark where there
ain't been no light so boy don't you
stop now don't you sit down on the steps
cuz you finds this kind of hard but I
still going boy I still climbing and
Life For Me ain't been no crystal
stair well life for none of us has been
a crystal
stair but we must keep moving we must
keep going if you can't
fly
run if you can't run
walk if you can't walk crawl but by all
means keep moving another super powerful
clip got to love Martin Luther King just
the message is so important for
entrepreneurs too every day you got to
keep moving every single day you got to
keep moving and sometimes you'll be
giant leaps forward and often more often
than not you're just crawling you're
slowly crawling forward but the key
thing is that you are moving every
single day I love it let's go to rule
number five follow your morals you live
the second march on Montgomery and
violation of a federal injunction not to
March I do feel that there are two types
of laws one is a just law and one is an
unjust law I think we all have moral
obligations to obey just laws on the
other hand I think we have moral
obligations to disobey unjust laws
because non-cooperation with evil is as
much a moral obligation as is
cooperation with good I think the
distinction here is that when one breaks
a law all the conscience tells him is
unjust he must do it openly he must do
it cheerfully he must do it lovingly he
must do it civil not unily and he must
do it with a willingness to accept the
penalty and any man who breaks the law
that conscience tells him is unjust and
willingly accepts the penalty by staying
in jail in order to arouse the
conscience of the community on the
Injustice of the law is at that moment
expressing the very highest respect for
law I really love the restraint that he
shows and I love how he can talk through
things and have it make sense and I
think for anybody who feels beaten down
for anybody who feels the laws are
unjust for anybody who feels like the
world is against them it's a fantastic
model to be able to follow Martin Luther
King learned from Gandhi on how to make
Progressive change and I think if you
want to have that kind of impact in your
world as well you can learn from both of
them too let's keep going to rule number
six act now
I'm sure you've heard this
idea it is the notion almost that is
something in the ver the very flow of
time that will miraculously cure all
evils and I've heard this over and over
again there are those and they often
sincere people who say to Negroes and
their allies in the white
community that we should slow up and
just be nice and patient and continue to
pray in 100 and or 200 years the problem
will work itself out because only time
can solve the
problem I think that is an answer to
that
myth and it is that time is
neutral it can be used either
constructively or
destructively and I'm absolutely
convinced that the forces of eill will
in our nation the extreme righteous in
our nation have often used time much
more effectively than the forces of
goodwi and it may well be that we will
have to repent in this generation not
merely for the vitriolic words of the
bad people and the violent actions of
the bad people but for the appalling
silence and indifference of the good
people who sit around and say wait on
time somewhere we must come to see that
social progress never rolls in on the
wheels of inevitability
it comes through the tireless efforts
and the persistent work of dedicated
individuals and without this hard
work time itself becomes an ally of the
Primitive forces of social stagnation
and so we must help
time and we must realize that the time
is always right to do right that one is
probably worth listening back a couple
times because it may not you may not
grasp it fully the first time through
but I love I love I love the idea of
taking personal responsibility taking
personal accountability and not just
blaming the people who are being mean to
you or doing bad things to you or
surrounding you or giving you conflict
but also the people who don't do
anything about it the people who
complain about and just sit on the couch
and are apathetic and never take any
kind of action if you want your world
and your life to change and you have to
get up and do something about it and act
now I love it let's move on to rule
number seven be determined to achieve
Excellence you must have as a basic
principle the determination to achieve
excellence in your various fields of
endeavor you're going to be deciding as
the days and the years unfold what you
will do in life what your life's work
will
be
and once you discover what it will be
set out to do it and to do it well if it
falls you love to be a street
sweeper sweep streets like Michelangelo
painted
pictures sweep streets like Beethoven
composed music sweep streets like Liam
te price sings before the Metro
Metropolitan
Opera and sweet sweep streets like
Shakespeare wrote
poetry sweep streets so well that all
the host of Heaven and Earth will have
to pause and say here lived a great
street sweeper who swept his job
well if you can't be a pine on the top
of the hill be a scrub in the
valley but be the best little scrub on
the side of the Reel be a bush if you
can't be a tree if you can't be a
highway just be a trail if you can't be
the Sun be a star for it isn't by size
that you win or you fail be the best of
whatever you are that's another
fantastic message guys this this top 10
is is next level I just love the idea
here of doing the best you can of
whatever you're doing and that you want
to leave a legacy and that you want to
be proud the work that you're putting
out and you want it to be something that
you show your grandkids with every video
that I make I want to show it to my
grandkids it's leaving that lasting
Legacy and so putting Pride into the
work that you do every single day will
make the difference and will lead you
down that path to Excellence let's move
to rule number eight stay true to your
principles how about your relationship
with the President Johnson have you lost
favor with Mr Johnson well I guess the
president would have to answer that
question uh I have taken a position
against administration's policy and uh I
would hope the president means what he
says when he uh says that there should
always be room for descent and we come
to a tragic period in our nation when we
equate desent with
disloyalty uh I believe firmly uh that
it is necessary to have these moments of
descent in order to challenge something
that may be leading the whole nation on
the wrong if you have lost favor with Mr
Johnson well that isn't uh I guess the
most important thing to me the important
thing is that I not lose favor with
truth and with what conscience tells me
is right and what conscience tells me is
just I'm much more concerned about
keeping favor with these principles than
keeping favor with a person who may
misunderstand the position I take guys
this is why it's so so so so important
that you understand what your principles
are this why I wrote the book your one
word whether you use this book or a
different method understanding what your
core value is what your core principle
is allows you to make the tough
decisions in life like defying the
president like going after your big
dream when everybody says that it's
impossible when you understand what your
core value your core principle is that
allows you to leave the life that you
want on your terms regardless of what
anybody else thinks so I love it Martin
Luther King thank you for the reminder
let's move on to rule number nine stand
for something all
labor has dignity
yes but you doing another
thing you are
reminding not only
Memphis but you are reminding the
nation that it is a
crime for
people to live in this Rich nation and
receive starvation wages I interview he
amazing and I think every entrepreneur
has a responsibility to stand for
something too that you take pride in the
work that you're doing and that you have
a mission to make the world a better
place somehow whatever you're doing in
the execution you are standing for
something that's how you're going to win
that's how you're going to get more
customers how you're going to make more
money it's how you're going to have that
big impact that you want to have I love
it I'm moving on to our final rule
number 10 have a dream I am happy to
join with you
today in what will go down in
history as the greatest demonstration
for freedom in the history of our
[Applause]
[Music]
nation
I have a
dream that my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character I have a dream
today with this phase we will be able to
work together to pray together to
struggle together to go to jail together
to stand up for Freedom together knowing
that we will be free one
day Let Freedom Ring and when this
happen when when we allow Freedom
Ring when we let it ring from every
village and every Hamlet from every
state and every city we will be able to
speed up that day when all of God's
children black men and white men Jews
and Gentiles Protestants and Catholics
will be able to join hands and sing in
the words of the old Negro
spiritual
[Music]
let's go hey keep order
keep so that's classic Martin Luther
King his greatest speech of all time I
got nothing else to add to that it's
been a real pleasure and honor to put
together this video I've wanted to do it
for a number of years now but we had a
hard time sourcing the right clips for
those of you interested in learning more
book I recommend the king years won the
P surprise uh amazing book gives you a
little more detail on the whole movement
if especially important if you want to
build your own movement good book to
pick up rule number one is probably my
personal favorite hard to pick cuz so
many great amazing rules that are worth
watching over and over and over again
but rule number one was about believe so
that's me I got to pick that I love to
know was rule number one your favorite
or was there one that was better that
hit you harder that had a bigger impact
on you please leave it down in the
comments below I'm really curious to
hear what you have to
say now I made this video because nadir
Ahmed asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description you can go to that video and
cast your vote for who we do next next I
also want to give a quick shout out to
best you pro thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the blog post about it
and sharing it with your audience it
really really really means a lot to me
man so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you
soon what has the Civil Rights Movement
done to the Negro individually from his
side I think the greatest thing that it
has done is that it has given the Negro
a new sense of dignity a new sense of
somebodiness and uh this is maybe the
greatest victory that we have
won uh turning away from the external
changes that have come about I think the
greatest thing that has taken place is
the internal change in the psyche uh of
the Negro and the Negro has a sense of
Pride now that he's desperately uh
needed all along and uh he is able to
stand up and uh feel that he is a man
and I think this is the only way
ultimately to solve the the real problem
and the problem that we must grapple
with in the future the Negro is
straighten his back up so to speak and
uh you can't ride a man's back unless
it's bent and by straightening up his
back uh he's made it possible to move on
in the future and make greater gain I
think our power must be much more than
military power we don't need to prove to
the world or anybody our military power
I think we got prove our moral power now
do you feel that this nation has abused
uh as you say uh their power oh I
certainly do in the in the war in
Vietnam I have no doubt about that I'm
not saying that it was done uh with evil
motives in mind I think we made a huge
miscalculation and when you make a
mistake you ought to confess it one of
the great things about President Kennedy
was that he said to the world to his
closest advisor that he made a mistake
in the Bay of Pigs invasion in Cuba and
he said I never should have listened to
the experts and I think the time has
come now for our leaders to say that
we've made a grave mistake in Vietnam
and we ought to take the initiative in
bringing an end to this conflict raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion can change the world for
the best not one drop of my selfworth
depends on your acceptance of me I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
Nation if you want want to see my
all-time favorite top 10 rules of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in the
description for
details